[Musique]
à
bonjour à tous c'est l'été le moment est
venu de jeter un coup d'oeil dans le
rétroviseur de cette année parlementaire
avec la crise du coronavirus on l'aurait
presque oublié mais cette session a été
marquée par une grande réforme la
réforme des retraites un long bras de
fer qui a débuté dans la rue et qui
s'est terminé ici même à l'assemblée
avec le 49-3 alors on va vous faire
revivre cette bataille parlementaire
mais avant cela on s'arrête sur ses
longues semaines de grèves et de
manifestations qui ont paralysé le pays
comment les députés ont ils tenté de
peser sur ce moment clé c'est à
découvrir dans ce reportage de la
rédaction des cp
c'est un mois de décembre qui a mis la
france à l'arrêt les trains sont restés
à quai les couloirs du métro ont fini
par déborder nous ultime de tout sans
répondre les plus entre le marteau et
l'enclume
il a fallu marcher pédaler la fatigue et
l'agacement ont fini par l'emporter
le stress l'énervement montait un peu
mais sarah les gens sont dans leur
voiture trois heures
cette idée une grève contre la réforme
des retraites
ce conte retrait total du projet de
système universel de retraitement
dans ce bras de fer entre gouvernement
et syndicats
à quoi ont servi les députés de la
majorité on mettra dans la loire que la
valeur du point ne pourra pas baissé
autant des députés on est aussi là pour
faire remonter les choses et là on va
pouvoir
j'ai eu beaucoup de remonter le beaucoup
d'inquiétudes et beaucoup
d'interrogations pourquoi la droite
s'est elle opposée à cette réforme
on voit de la clarté là où le
gouvernement met de la confusion et
chacun se sent en réalité mis en danger
par cette réponse c'est pas où on va on
sait pas combien on va gagner le
gouvernement c'est pas tant la réforme
de retraites cnued environ générale dans
le pays
dans cette lutte quel est l objectif d
un sont mis d'accord
[Musique]
leur réforme va faire manger la terre un
maximum de monde
monsieur macron nous allons tout faire
pour vous faire battre en retraite
voici comment trois députés ont tenté de
peser dans cette bataille de l'opinion
[Musique]
depuis trois mois celui qui n'est encore
qu'un député en marche
laurent pietrasinski balade sa bouteille
d'eau et sa petite sacoche aux quatre
coins de la france il joue les vrp de la
réforme des retraites
ce jour-là il est invité par le député
de la circonscription de bourges
laurent pietrasinski dirige un pôle
d'ambassadeur retraite
la task force de l'assemblée pour faire
passer la réforme
nous sommes le 2 décembre dans trois
jours va avoir lieu la première
manifestation contre la réforme est pas
facile de convaincre quand le projet
final du gouvernement n'est pas encore
connue en août sujet c'était simplement
d'être sur le terrain avant la fin de
l'année le plus possible pour à la fois
recueillir les questionnements les
interrogations mais aussi peut-être les
approbations les envies et partagés sur
cette réforme c'était ça notre objectif
donc on regarde on tient c'est pour ça
qu'on est là soir dans tous les esprits
une inquiétude comment être sûr que la
valeur du point et donc le niveau des
retraites ne baissera pas au fil des
années alors laurent pietra zf ce qui
leur garantit que les députés joueront
les garde-fous on mettra dans la loi que
la valeur du point ne pourra pas baisser
à quelques jours de l'annoncé du projet
on en est encore à consulter les
citoyens leur demander de lister des
propositions qu'ils aimeraient voir
figurer dans la loi à carrière identique
retraite identique
que ce soit dans le privé ou dans le
public un mode de financement avec des
bases hors salaires peut-être une
taxation sur les robots haute pour
contribuer aux caisses de retraite
une méthode qui pour les députés
permettra de mieux peser sur la réforme
des retraites
non la chance d'être dans un moment
d'échangé
je pense plutôt aux mamans intéressant
utile on peut dire et c'est aussi
valorisant pour les députés parce que
quand elle est discutée
on est aussi là pour faire remonter les
choses et là on pourra le faire comme
lui
une quarantaine d'ambassadeurs ont
sillonné les territoires pour recueillir
l'avis des français pour que les
propositions des citoyens ne reste pas
lettre morte
ce matin-là à l'assemblée les députés
ambassadeur reçoivent le monsieur
retraites de l'époque au gouvernement
[Musique]
en tant que responsable des ambassadeurs
laurent pietrasinski se veut l'écho des
préoccupations des français
avi
[Musique]
merci à jean paul d'être là merci pour
votre habitation
il veut surtout pouvoir respecter
l'engagement qu'il a pris auprès des
citoyens lors des réunions publiques
notamment sur le niveau du point alors
il va alerter jean paul delevoye sur
cette question on a des vraies questions
des vraies interrogations qui nous sont
portés à chaque fois sur la valeur du
point comment est-ce que cela va durer
dans le temps comment vous pouvez nous
garantir que notre porte s'ouvre va pas
baisser donc on a des vraies questions
sur le fond sur le montant de la pension
plus que de remonter les propositions
les ambassadeurs volts alerte et jean
paul delevoye sur l'ambiance générale
le fond de l'air est négatif sujet
important des enseignants c'est le sujet
moi j'ai eu 31 personnes à la réunion la
semaine dernière dans le val de marne
j'ai eu beaucoup de remontées beaucoup
d'inquiétudes et beaucoup
d'interrogations de les inciter la part
d'enseignants
voilà ce que je ressens aujourd'hui
c'est pas tant la réforme de retraites
qui pose problème
ces niveaux d'ambiance générale dans
notre pays qui le plombe
en réalité toutes les dynamiques de
réformes qu'on met en place michel santi
dire qu'on fait
l'ambiance générale n'est pas bonne il
ya un fond négatifs pour plein de
raisons
et évidemment quand on arrive avec ça et
quand même un épandeur donc là ça
sache que tu entres nous sommes à 48
heures de la grande manifestation contre
les retraites et jean paul delevoye lui
n'est pas inquiet la remontée du terrain
perception des députés sur les questions
des citoyens voire se plie obtiennent
leur adhésion ce qui suscite
l'inquiétude
ça permet de clarifier un débat loin des
agitations médiatiques mais les députés
vont-ils vraiment pesé sur le texte
alors que les attaques contre la réforme
arrive de toute part d'abord par la
droite
damien abad le chef de file des
républicains à l'assemblée est un peu
gêné favorable à une réforme des
retraites
il ne sait pas quel angle d'attaqué
utilisés il prépare un contre-projet
rappelant que son groupe politique
connaît bien le sujet on a de la
crédibilité parce que les trois réformes
qui ont été menées sur les retraites
sont été faites par des gouvernements de
droite en 93 en 2003 et en 2010 ensuite
parce que on voit de la clarté là où le
gouvernement met de la confusion la
clarté sur l'âge légal la clarté sur le
dispositif de retraite sur la défense
des artisans des commerçants des
salariés du privé et finalement de
toutes les françaises et les français en
2010 c'est eric woerth qui a fait passer
l'âge de départ de 60 à 62 ans il a
connu les manifestations les oppositions
et il attaque le gouvernement sur la
méthode
quand on veut réformer il faut pouvoir
expliquer sa réforme
c'est une base de discussion dans une
démocratie et la réforme que porte le
gouvernement est une réforme qui est
inexplicable donc incomprise et chacun
se sent en réalité mis en danger par
cette réforme
à juste titre ou pas mais c'est comme ça
que les français le problème des
critiques qui ont bien du mal à se faire
entendre
car un autre front d'opposition est bien
plus médiatique
il se situe à la gauche de la gauche
nous sommes à lille adrien catane ans a
rendez vous ce soir avec les électeurs
de sa circonscription
un tour de chauffe avant la grande
manifestation du lendemain
pour ce proche de jean luc mélenchon
le député de la france insoumise cherche
la bonne formule
l'argument qui fera mouche et il affûte
sa stratégie ça fait partie de l'arsenal
incontestablement il faut pouvoir mettre
des mots précis sur ce qu en train de se
passer et il faut pouvoir faire des
démonstrations
moi je vois très bien comment ça se
passe quand quelqu'un trouve un bon
argument et le diffuse ça peut être tout
à fait viral sur les réseaux sociaux
tels arguments ce rediffuse puis on
passe des réseaux sociaux à la machine à
café entre collègues au repas de famille
du dimanche
et c'est comme ça en fait que la
contagion ce fait on peut faire que ce
pari là si vous voulez donc l'objectif
il est il est simple il se résume en peu
de mots que le gouvernement retire sa
réforme
avec cette réforme le gouvernement veut
plafonner à 14% du pib la part des
richesses consacrée aux retraites
adrien catane ans a mis sur papier ses
formules chocs
il nous présente celle qui résume le
mieux ce qui est en jeu à 6 ie
moi j'ai trouvé cette métaphore pour
schématiser en fait et illustrer ce que
fait manuel macron c'est un peu comme si
vous vous receviez des gens à table
et puis vous avez un gâteau mais de la
table vous savez que les gens vont être
toujours plus nombreux à table ils vont
arriver de plus en plus nombreux et vous
dites moi je refuse de cuisine et un
plus gros gâteau c'est ce que fait
emmanuel macron travaux pratiques
quelques heures plus tard
le meeting a lieu en centre ville il va
permettre aux députés de roder ses
arguments et de mobiliser les troupes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'équipe du député a vu grand pour
l'occasion trois caméras une régie deux
écrans géants
le tout retransmis en direct sur les
réseaux sociaux
la salle est pleine
très vite adrien catane 1 ce test cette
image du ghetto qui nous avait présenté
un peu plus tôt 14 % du pib
c'est comme si vous d'ailleurs au moment
de recevoir pour les fêtes dans quelques
jours vous disiez bon voila j'ai cuisiné
un gâteau et finalement il ya plus
d'invités qui arrive à table et vous
dites je cuisinerai pas un plus gros
gâteau on va jusqu'où plus petite
part de ce même gâteau voilà le mépris
qu franc succès pour la métaphore le
député insoumis enchaîne alors les
formules courtes et percutantes pour
qu'elle soit reprise par les militants
leur réforme va faire manger la terre un
maximum de monde oui comparativement au
système actuel
la réforme des manuels macron concernera
tout le monde et ne fera que des
perdants
ne succombons pas à la division qu'ils
vont essayer de jouer entre les français
dès demain ni succombons par et soyez
contagion en sortant de cette salle
aussi en repartant des arguments dans
votre besace
l'objectif est clair qu'il remballe leur
réforme des retraites
monsieur macron nous allons tout faire
pour vous faire battre en retraite
adrien kenneth fed emmanuel macron sa
cible principale
la salle applaudit mission accomplie
[Musique]
il est 22 heures
adrien catena a déjà les yeux tournés
vers la journée du lendemain
avec plus de 250 manifestations annoncé
partout en france demain on verra les
chiffres mais en toute hypothèse qui
tint dit qu'on lui que ça sera massif
ensuite et effectivement c'est un
rapport de force qui s'engagent vaudrait
mieux que ça soit durable il faut qu'on
puisse y aider nous vraiment l'essentiel
c'est d'être dans l'action et pour être
au coeur de l'action le député doit
rejoindre paris le soir même un retour
en voiture car la grève à la sncf vient
de commencer
plus aucun train ne circule le pays
retient son souffle
la réforme des retraites prônée par le
gouvernement grévistes et manifestants
savoir jeudi sa maison ses membres
accusés de 6000 policiers et gendarmes
le capitaine
jeudi 5 décembre jour de la grande
manifestation contre la réforme
laurent pietrasinski est sur le pied de
guerre dès 6h30 le monsieur retraites
des députés en marche se lance dans une
tournée de plateaux télé les forces de
l'ordre sont prêtes
la journée dans la rue s'annonce animé
et le dpt est presque inquiet ça sera
dans cela on s'attend
journée de grève importante mois
j'écouterai les messages et pour
commencer un cerveau aujourd'hui une
matinale très écoutée celle de rmc et
bfm tv
on a appris la veille que le premier
ministre devrait bientôt annoncer le
contenu de la réforme mais on ne sait
pas quel jour exactement la date de
l'annoncé devenue la question du jour et
soudain à l'antenne on annonce une date
laurent pietra zeiss qui n'en revient
pas une des seuils d'obtenir
confirmation
en vain bientôt c'est son tour de
rentrer dans l'arène
ce jour là le présentateur va se révéler
particulièrement en forme notamment sur
le silence du gouvernement
d'abord est-ce que le gouvernement
volontairement n'a toujours pas présenté
sa réforme des retraites
on voit bien que les français
rencontrent la réforme maintenant
d'ailleurs ce même sur les coûts dans le
premier cas vous la connaissez dans son
entièreté
non laurent pietrasinski se fait
bousculer ce toit alors il va un peu
savant s'est joint le fait qu'il faut
pouvoir le conclure ce débat quand
connaîtrons la réforme des retraites du
gouvernement
quand proposition de jean paul delevoye
lundi 9 et mardi 10 réactions rapides et
arbitrage du premier ministre le 12
c'est à dire que nous connaîtrons la
réforme des retraites le 12
écoutez cet hiver bon eh ben voilà une
information nous connaîtrons la réforme
des retraites le 12 billes
et en sortant les journalistes
politiques lui demande de confirmer la
date du 12
j'ai repris j'ai repris bfm qui disait
soft non non c'est pas mon info c'est
pas mon info ouais c'est pas mon info et
bfm qui a dit ça tout à l'heure donc
j'ai voulu dire
il m'a repris la main à tout de suite
mais c'est pas mon un faux nom le comble
c'est que l'information du xii a été
lancé par cette même chaîne
mais qu'en réalité personne ne sait rien
décision oui précision parce que j'étais
seul dans le couloir juste avant
d'arriver donc j'ai pas eu le temps de
regarder mes messages moi j'ai pas de
confirmation c'est faux bfm
oui mais donc je voulais vous rajoutez
ainsi j'ai entendu dans le truc j'ai pas
pu finalement l'information lancée par
la chaîne tout info s'avérera fausse le
premier ministre s'exprimera le 11
décembre
la journée médiatique du député ne fait
que commencer
pas facile de se faire entendre quand la
rue hurle son opposition
un texte encore inconnue et les
syndicats ont su mobiliser leurs troupes
au coeur de paris drapeaux banderoles
slogans tout y est
la gauche a aussi répondu présente dans
la manifestation
adrien catena occupe l'espace médiatique
le député insoumis enchaîne interviews
et duplex sur les chaînes info pour lui
pas de doute sa place est ici aux côtés
des manifestants
un député s'est là aussi pour
représenter le peuple français doit être
à la fois un pied dans l'institution
faire la loi et là dessus on pourrait
compter sur eux ont fait le travail au
cas pas de souci là dessus mais c'est
aussi d'être présent dans les
mobilisations effectivement et de les
accompagner
lorsque le peuple expriment des
revendications qui nous paraissent tout
à fait juste
et c'est avec l'hymne des gilet jaune
que le député en soumis épaulé par
alexis corbière accompagne la
manifestation
à quelques mètres de là france insoumise
le parti socialiste a lui aussi son
refrain
cendrillon 70 ans ses droits photo
olivier faure députée et premier
secrétaire du parti ainsi qu'une poignée
d'élus socialistes font leur grand
retour dans une manifestation
mais on se félicite mais le coeur n'y
est pas vraiment surtout quand les
socialistes croiser la route de
militants déçus je suis un ancien de la
jeunesse socialiste
quand on a vu ce qui s'est passé voilà
voilà vous avez oublié les fondamentaux
vous avez tout oublié non quand là nous
on a les valeurs et on est toujours là
pas trahi donc venir tu peux bien c'est
pour critiquer tu peux continuer là-bas
on se quitte bons amis des socialistes
un peu chahuté il faut dire que les
politiques ne sont pas forcément les
bienvenus dans cette manifestation
notamment du côté des filets jaunes
j'attends rien de mes députés parce que
je pense qu'on a un vrai problème avec
la représentativité
c'est notre première phrase un les
députés votent en notre nom
sauf que c'est absolument pas vrai
peut-être un petit peu moins ce qu'on
appelle maintenant l'extrême gauche
attention la france a soumises ils ont
encore un petit peu ma confiance donc
j'espère qu'il n'a trahi rompt pas
on peut abuser faire une photo avec
effectivement la popularité d'adrien
catena se mesure au nombre de celles
fille mais le député insoumis ne perd
pas de vue son objectif diffuser les
arguments les marteler en faisant le
pari de la contagion j'ai vu que depuis
deux semaines
le soutien à la mobilisation a augmenté
de 10 francs c'est à dire que nos
arguments commencent à vraiment pas
c'est quoi
organisme de soutien à la rumination ça
c'est bien variez vos camarades là en
l'espace de 10 jours là on a gagné 10
points de soutien à la mobilisation ce
n'est pas rien ça veut dire que les
argumentaires commence à passer n'ai pas
trouvé mieux et cerise sur le gâteau je
dis aux gens c'est comme si vous
receviez des invités chez vous vous avez
cuisine et un gâteau et puis finalement
arrive plus d'invités que prévu et la
grenouille départ macro heavy je ne
cuisine pas un plus gros gâteau tous ici
espèrent faire reculer le gouvernement
sur une réforme qu'ils estiment injuste
[Musique]
dans son bureau de l'assemblée laurent
pietrasinski lui suit en direct les
manifestations
celui qui a été aux ressources humaines
du groupe auchan durant sept ans se rêve
en homme de dialogue
on peut pas transformer un pays sans une
large adhésion
on a besoin de l'adhésion il faut qu'on
a construit alors mais en même temps ça
veut pas dire que il ya unanimité
on est aussi en république en démocratie
on a été élu on est légitime on est élu
par une majorité
nous on applique notre programme mais on
n'a pas vocation à le faire contre des
ans ou contre les autres on veut le
faire dans le plus large consensus et la
façon pour lui de jouer le consensus est
d'imposer les thèmes évoqués dans les
réunions
il finalise une série de dix
propositions qu'il va faire au
gouvernement et le député veut donner la
priorité aux fins de carrière il
faudrait avant d'être à la retraite
pouvoir travailler à temps partiel
on prend les gens qu'on vend 45 50 ans
aujourd'hui c'est comment ils peuvent se
maintenir dans l'emploi
surtout quand on leur présente la notion
d'âge dès qu'ils vivent donc comment ils
se maintiennent dans l'emploi ils
peuvent se maintenir dans l'emploi et ça
peut passer aussi par une diminution du
temps de travail
ce que le député a retenu des réunions
publiques
c'est aussi que tout le monde ne peut
pas être logé à la même enseigne
nous avons entendu que le sujet de la
pénibilité était un sujet récurrent là
aussi on entend bien que ceux qui ne
bénéficient pas aujourd'hui de la
pénibilité sont en attente de cela ils
sont en attente que ça soit équitable
comme les premiers qui sont sont
exprimés mais ils sont en attente qu'on
reconnaisse la difficulté de leur
activité mais ce que ça signifie que
vous préconisez que certaines
professions parts avant soit 104
oui il est clair que la pénibilité ça
doit générer un départ anticipé
pendant que le député réfléchit à des
mesures pour apaiser la colère
dans le cortège on continue de piétiner
mais pour adrien catena si ça n'avance
pas c'est plutôt bon signe
mais vu sa série en est aussi gros 95
millions pour ça j'avais 5 ans g
j'ai connu ça moi du jamais vu pour le
jeune député insoumis qui estime que le
rapport de forces est bien engagée
effectivement il faut durer mais je
crois que le plus dur pour le
gouvernement commence aussi il a en face
de lui un peuple déterminé qui ne se
laissera pas conter quoi que ce soit je
vous le dis très franchement la semaine
prochaine ils peuvent venir avec tous
les arbitrages qu'ils font mais
décryptera en personne sera du voilà à
mesure que le temps passe les gens ont
affûté leurs arguments et leur analyse
de la situation
ce jour là plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes ont défilé partout
en france
cette démonstration de force va-t-elle
peser sur les avances d'edouard philippe
et enfin le jour tant attendu arrive
nous sommes le 11 décembre le premier
ministre edouard philippe choisi le
conseil économique et social pour
détailler l'ensemble de son plan pour
réformer les retraites
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les membres du conseil
économique social et environnemental
le temps est venu de construire un
système universel de retraite
l'allocution est retransmise à la
télévision
chez les républicains damien abad
écoutent avec attention le discours du
premier ministre
les femmes seront les grandes gagnantes
du système universel blague beaucoupde
annonce et une surtout qui retient son
attention
nous allons devoir inciter les français
à travailler plus longtemps
des coptes font qui consiste à instaurer
le pivot avec un système devant un truc
de faux cul parce que tu as l'âge légal
je trouve pas départ contre vingt décote
surcote
donc tu a flingué btp pas c'est
l'appauvrissement
c'est vraiment système de faux culs quoi
c'est agir alors que je les assumerai
malgré la pression de la rue edouard
philippe n'a pas renoncé à l'âge pivot à
64 ans un choix qui crispe aussi les
insomnies
[Musique]
il vient progressivement déplacé place
avec une retraite pourri les libertés
comme et donc oui mesdames et messieurs
le temps est bien venu de construire un
système universel de re
[Applaudissements]
toute chose qui m
pour les républicains le problème est
que ces mesures vont creuser les
déficits
gilles carez membre de la commission des
finances en est persuadé moi j'ai écouté
la toulon la seyne pendant pendant leur
entière si tu veux la difficulté qu'on
va avoir c'est que comme toujours
l'emballage l'emballage est sympathique
enfin tu vois il nous explique en gros
ont leur système qu'ils ont ils vont
faire des transitions pour les artisans
des transitions pour les régimes
spéciaux - ce qui m'a frappé c'est qu'il
ya eu aucun chiffre donné pendant une
heure là les comptes ils vont se
dégrader à grande vitesse donc on ment
ça veut dire que parce que à quoi peut
que j'ai entendu ça veut dire que non
dans deux ans dans trois ans va ils vont
laisser un énorme trou en 2022
mais alors que les républicains affinent
leurs angles d'attac un rebondissement
va changer la donne
jean paul delevoye le père de la réforme
s'avère avoir été rémunéré par un think
tank alors qu'il est membre du
gouvernement ce qui est totalement
interdit
à l'assemblée nationale l'opposition
attaque et c'est encore la france
insoumise qui dirige la tête du haut
commissaire la parole à monsieur adrien
captens dans sa déclaration d'intérêts
monsieur delevoye déclare jusqu'à la
plus insignifiante de ses fonctions
bénévoles mais oublient de déclarer ses
liens avec le monde de l'assurance
monsieur le premier ministre
est-il encore bien raisonnable de
laisser les retraites du pays entre les
mains de monsieur delevoye je vous pose
la question lapin le top chez alexis
corbière
mais quand mais quand cet homme siège au
conseil d'administration du 9 durand
steve hill vous prenez ça normal vous
trouvez cela normal
eh bien il est alors conflit d'intérêts
oui monsieur de loi vous n'êtes plus
l'homme de la situation pour mener cette
réforme des retraites parce qu'on nous
fait pas confiance
quelques jours plus tard face à la
pression jean paul delevoye est obligé
de démissionner et pour le remplacer
laurent pietrasinski bonne chance
laurent je suis ravi que ce chemin qui
me succède présent je te connais et je
vous remercie tous désole
députés entrent au gouvernement une
place de choix pour influencer le texte
qui passera devant l'assemblée nationale
en début d'année
[Musique]
ce projet de loi est arrivée quelques
semaines plus tard ici même à
l'assemblée cela n'a pas été de tout
repos après les manifestants ce sont les
députés de l'opposition qui ont pris le
relais de la contestation une bataille
épique comme on en n'avait pas vécu
depuis longtemps elle s'est jouée à
coups d'amendements de motion de censure
de rappels au règlement
une guerre des nerfs que nous vous
proposons de revivre avec ce reportage
de la rédaction des cp 28 janvier 2020
la réforme des retraites arrive à
l'assemblée
la droite veut marquer les esprits elle
sort les écharpes tricolores pour
dénoncer une réforme mal préparée
un texte incomplet qu'il faut examiner
dans un calendrier trop serré
c'est votre amateurisme qui court du
rail on le sait au 49 3 et au déni de
démocratie
un déni de démocratie c'est aussi ce que
dénonce la gauche
un mois plus tard la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre edouard
philippe sort une arme fatale
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 j'ai décidé
d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite comment en est on arrivé là
on est lundi les 9h15 il reste 33 1791
amendements tous les moyens ont été
utilisés pour ralentir les débats on va
leur pourrir la vie parce qu'ils veulent
courir les retraites
je redemande mesure où ces mentions de
séance et je redemande un scrutin public
sur la suspension de séance
dites aux français que vous assumez
votre obstruction la bataille s'est joué
sur quelques mots quelques dates
nous proposons à travers cette belle
série d'amendements de repousser à plus
tard
l'entrée en vigueur de votre réforme
2057 au lieu de 2022 2058 2055 au kazoo
jusqu'à 2082 et même au delà
une guerre des nerfs pour la majorité
vous imposez le monologue et le
monologue c'est simplement l'antichambre
des dictatures quelle image donne au
niveau des travaux
dans cette bataille pour remporter la
mise
et ben ya eu des coups de bluff des
coups bas des imprévus aussi chacun à
jouer ses atouts avec un seul objectif
faire craquer l'adversaire
17h01 vendredi soir à l'assemblée
à l'heure où tout le monde part en week
end les bureaux de la france insoumise
sont dans une étrange effervescence le
texte c'est le deuxième c'est la loi
ordinaire
ok pour créer un amendement est une
icône ici il faut cliquer dessus
là tu marques présentées par autant il a
autant qui marquent et là c'est parfait
tu descends descends ses collaborateurs
déposent des amendements par milliers
avant l'examen en commission il ne
s'agit pas d'améliorer le texte mais de
le supprimer
alinéa par alinéa une stratégie assumée
je fais cette adresse prix ok et là tu
fais pas déposer tu fait enregistrer
dupliquer pour faire du volume
chaque amendement est dupliquée 17 fois
au nom des dix sept députés du groupe
de quoi mettre en surchauffe le logiciel
de l'assemblée
ouais ça rame un petit peu parce que là
ça fait un peu buggé la machine mais ça
marche on n'en veut ça y est la matrice
ils vont être commentant le service
informatique
je pense que oui voilà accusé chaque
amendement donnera droit à deux minutes
de temps de parole
un jackpot paroles que vous gagnez bac
on espère pouvoir à voir et surtout du
temps de réponse pour que le
gouvernement réponde un peu
franchement et honnêtement aux questions
donc voilà on dispose de ce moyen là eh
bien on va l'utiliser
la bataille peut commencer la première
manche va se jouer ici en commission
spéciale
elle va examiner le texte pendant neuf
jours avec pas moins de six rapporteur
comme une répétition générale avant
l'hémicycle face à la majorité
un petit groupe de députés communistes
socialistes et insoumis qui partagent la
même table la discussion promet d'être
longue
nous débutons donc aujourd'hui l'examen
des 21 1661 amendements déposés sur les
projets de loi instituant un système
universel l'opération de la france
insoumise n'était donc pas du bluff
plus de 21 mille amendements 19 1700
rien que pour le groupe de jean luc
mélenchon les députés insoumis prennent
la main il ne la lâcheront plus donc
l'amendement 796 madame atteint oui
c'est un amendement de suppression nous
proposons de supprimer l'article
intégralement monsieur bernalicis met
donc il s'agit de supprimer cette année
à 8
ensuite le 3423 madame aux tables oui
nous continuons donc notre travail pour
dépecer ce texte
au troisième jour on en est toujours à
l'article premier d'un texte qui en
compte 64 les esprits s'échauffent
je suis navré de voir que nous sommes
davantage dans un vaudeville ce soir que
dans un véritable débat parlementaire
quelle conception de la démocratie avez
vous mon cher collègue s'il vous plaît
de grâce
remballez définitivement vos leçons de
démocratie merci tout le monde se calme
après neuf jours de débats moins d'un
tiers des amendements ont été examinées
la présidente de la commission jette
l'épongé alors je prends à que notre
commission n'est pas en mesure d'achever
la discussion des articles du projet de
loi ordinaire
merci
les travaux s'arrêtent sans être arrivé
à la fin du texte les députés ont donc
siéger pour rien ils repartiront de zéro
dans l'hémicycle c'est une première
c'est du foutage de gueule c'est l'unité
l'inutilité totale
une commission spéciale on a passé
beaucoup de temps beaucoup d'énergie
beaucoup d'argent public également pour
au final dire circulez ya rien à voir
tout ce qu'on aura débattu en commission
spéciale ne sert à rien puisque en fait
on va revenir avec le texte initial du
gouvernement on le savait les insoumis
eux revendiquent une première victoire
et la gauche se tourne déjà vers la
bataille suivante celle de l'hémicycle
on va faire mieux on va évidemment
entrer dans tous les détails
aucun ne leur sera épargné ça va donc
prendre des semaines et des semaines et
des semaines va additionner nos
arguments additionner nos forces on va
leur pourrir la vie parce qu'ils veulent
pourrir les retraites et on va le faire
par tous moyens
c'est sur ces bons que va se jouer l'une
des réformes majeures du quinquennat
deux semaines sont prévues une troisième
est possible pas au dollar a décidé le
gouvernement la majorité n'a pas pu
amendé le texte en commission
elle entend se rattraper dans
l'hémicycle parmi les députés en marche
catherine fabre et monique limon elles
ont sillonné la france pendant un an
pour défendre cette réforme et elles se
disent prêtes à faire face à
l'obstruction
il n'est pas question comme ça a pu être
dit de se taire tout le temps mais de
parler au bon moment et pour dire les
choses de fond quand on est dans ces
conditions là on est obligé de choisir
d'être court et percutant
donc c'est ce qu'on essaiera de faire
c'est pas dur de rester calme face à des
écoutes et c'est une vraie preuve c'est
une vraie preuve de zénitude met
justement en train de progresser là
c'est pas mal
restez zen ne pas céder aux provocations
ce sera tout l'enjeu de la nouvelle
partie qui commence
et dans cette seconde manche les
insoumis ne sont plus seuls
ils vont pouvoir compter sur le soutien
des communistes c'est le jour j à
l'assemblée dans moins d'une heure
commence le débat sur la réforme des
retraites micros tendus caméra au poing
ont filmé on écoute on enregistre
et voilà qu'un des acteurs du débat se
présente face aux journalistes
sourire en coin jean luc mélenchon est
impatient d'en découdre à l'élan chez
moi aujourd'hui c'est une vraie taille
d'obstruction qui commence à l'assemblée
alors c'est une très grande bataille
parlementaire qui commence
rien ne nous fait peur rien ne nous
arrêtera ni maintenant ni jamais c'est
une déclaration de guerre
la majorité s'y attendait face à nous
nous avons des oppositions qui ont
décidé d'hystériser ce débat de le
bloquer d'empêcher qu'ils aient lieu
nous sommes parfaitement prêts à
accepter d enrichissement de ce texte
mais en aucun cas nous nous laisseront
entraîner dans une spirale qui est
dangereuse pour notre institution
l'assemblée nationale et aussi pour
notre démocratie
un groupe de députés fait alors son
entrée salle des quatre colonnes tee
shirt blanc lettres rouges
chacun prend place il faut se mettre
dans le bon ordre pour former un mot
référendum
nous avons décidé de proposer une motion
référendaire
le peuple doit avoir la parole c'est
d'ailleurs un des fondements de la 5ème
république
nous allons demander donc un référendum
dans votre corps lieu ce soir référendum
les communistes ont passé la semaine à
recueillir 60 signatures
mais si un seul signataire manquent à
l'appel dans l'hémicycle tout tombe à
l'eau pas de vote pour réclamer ce
référendum
la carte est donc posée mais il faut
maintenant transformer l'essai
la séance va commencer
tous les signataires de la motion
référendaire doivent rejoindre
l'hémicycle
[Musique]
c'est la motion référendaire oui
seulement il y a des retardataires on
les cherche
on s'inquiète l'opération risque de
capoter la clémentine autain monsieur
alexis corbière monsieur ugo bernalicis
richard ferrand égrène les noms des 60
signataires jusqu'au verdict final est
enfin madame à karamanli acte est donnée
de la présence effective en séance des
signataires de la motion
la parole est à monsieur fabien roussel
le débat va commencer de député en
profite alors pour s'éclipser léventine
autant a rejoint rassemblement devant
l'assemblée
aux côtés de la députée insoumise
la communiste est la faucille ont elles
ne portent pas des sharks tricolore car
ici on est plutôt blouse bleue et
foulard rouge un coup de main
le début des sénatrices pour un con et
évidemment quand je compare
la migration
deux mamans et la chute des pensions
pour voitures et marion
à cet instant info emmanuel macron enisa
terre sous les yeux des deux députés
[Musique]
un acte symbolique qui fera polémique il
est l'heure de retourner dans
l'hémicycle pour voter la motion
référendaire
le scrutin est clos votants 230 jory t
116 pour 70 contre 160
la motion référendaire n'est pas adopté
sans surprise la motion est rejetée
mais la bataille ne fait que commencer
et donc ils vont se bouffer une bonne
pelletée d'amendements et chacun membres
sera l'occasion de défendre pied à pied
notre projet
bravo à toutes et tous nos dents dehors
j'en suis sûr
nous faisons une belle équipe merci à
toutes et tous et bravo la séance est
ouverte
la pelletée d'amendements la voici
il y en a quarante et un mille un record
pour cette législature la moitié vient
des insoumis et 13000 des communistes
en face le président de l'assemblée dans
un conte une carte qui permet de
supprimer des amendements par centaines
j'ai eu l'occasion en conférence des
présidents d'indiquer que cette règle
logique sera appliquée de manière
systématique
il en sera donc ainsi fait mais si si si
si si c'est la règle puisque j'ai le
micro la règle a changé que tous les
collègues comprennent va pas changer ce
dont il s'agit permettez moi d'expliquer
des centaines de nos amendements vont
tomber avec une raie qui a changé en
cours de route monsieur le président
vous êtes en train de faire en sorte de
trouver une nouvelle arme pour museler
le parlement vous êtes en train
d'inventer à la faveur de cela une
nouvelle arme pour museler votre
position oui il y à ici un front
républicain qui dit que cet hémicycle et
cadenassé que cet hémicycle et martyrisé
et que cet hémicycle
nous voulons le libérer vous avez la
parole droite et gauche réunies
défendent leur droit d'amendement face à
richard ferrand vous vous bâillonner le
le débat regardez nous n'avons pas
déposé plus d'amendements que votre
majorité dont vous me dites qu'il s'agit
d'un bâillon alors qu'il restera minime
à 39 mille amendements à débattre croyez
- croyez moi vous aurez le temps
d'exprimer tous vos arguments simplement
richard ferrand veut accélérer les
débats l'opposition va user de toutes
ses cartes pour les faire traîner
au nom de l'article 100 je souhaite
faire un rappel au règlement
je vais demander une suspension de
séance et mon président un scrutin
public
la scène va se répéter plusieurs fois je
redemande
je suis aussi l'attention de séance et
je redemande un scrutin public sur la
suspension de séance la séance suspendue
pour cinq minutes les députés quittent
l'hémicycle à bout de nerfs car
l'épisode leur a déjà fait perdre une
journée
l'institution s'abîme aujourd'hui dans
la façon dont une partie de l'opposition
est en train de dévoyer le débat
parlementaire
le calme a décidément du mal à revenir
les députés vont jusqu'à se couper la
parole le chef d'un chef de clan
l'hystérie des marchés
aleri des marcheurs on ne peut pas
appliquer jamais fait ça et vite mes
enfants j'ai honte vis-à-vis de tous
ceux qui nous regardent qui nous
écoutent aujourd'hui c'est incroyable on
est en train de discuter de 2,2
juridique alors qu'on voit un débat aux
français sous la pression de richard
ferrand fini par céder il retire sa
carte mais il prévient ce matin à 9h30
6476 amendement était encore en
discussion
à ce rythme mais le 640 trois heures de
séances seront nécessaires pour terminer
la seule loi ordinaire soit 150 jours de
séance commence alors une guerre d'usure
les séances se suivent et se ressemblent
la séance est ouverte
la majorité pointe du doigt
l'obstruction et ses amendements qui ne
changent souvent qu'un mot ou une
virgule
il reste 33 1791 amendements et on nous
propose de remplacer réduction par
diminution constante par continue et
préparez vous parce que dans quelques
minutes monsieur mélenchon va nous
proposer de remplacer assurant par
garantissant et madame obono de
remplacer assurance garantissant pas
rassurant dans ce spectacle chacun tient
son rôle celui des insoumis et de crier
au scandale mais que voulez-vous à la
fin une opposition qui ne s'opposent pas
qui ne demandent pas de supprimer les
articles de loi et qui ne veut pas mais
ça n'existe pas il ya quelques jours de
totalitaire dans ce rappel 107 au genre
oui oui de totalitaire voulu vous ne
nous offrez aucune possibilité d'entrer
dans une discussion
car quoi que l'on dise vous est contée
vous criez donc buvait un bon coup
respire un bon coup d'air frais et ça
ira mieux après
je dharréville c'est à qui craquera le
premier et à ce petit jeu les
communistes et des insoumis savent
parfaitement comment s'y prendre au
neuvième jour des débats
il dégaine une série de 700 amendements
pour changer année après année la date
d'application de la réforme
nous vous proposons avait à travers
cette cette belle série d'amendements de
repousser à plus tard
l'entrée en vigueur de votre réforme
nous demandons son application à partir
de 2050 7 au lieu de 2022 on porte
boréart fait de reporter à 2058 nous
proposons donc de la repousser au delà
donc dans le premier amendement 2056
dans le suivant 2055 au kazoo oui on est
bien évidemment d'accord pour repousser
votre réforme des retraites jusqu'à 2082
et même au delà on est dans un tunnel de
700 amendements identiques qui vont
remplacer 2022 par 2060 de gaprée 2060
et à 2060 et cth cas de nul 2022 quand
est ce qu'on va pouvoir débattre on
trouve qu'il ya une imprécision dans
l'amendement proposé par nos camarades
communistes et on suggère de remplacer
au parent à tous les la majorité dénonce
l'absurdité du débat avant de quitter
l'hémicycle
nous reviendrons lorsque enfin nous
pourrons débattre
[Applaudissements]
bon voila mais nous on va continuer à
faire notre travail ici le pas deux
merci beaucoup monsieur d'arrivée mes
chers collègues la majorité finit par
revenir
mais à ce jeu là certains s'épuise après
neuf jours de commissions et autant
d'hémicycle à rézé le rapporteur le
rapporteur nicolas turquois ne cache pas
sa fatigue
tout à l'heure vous voulez pas du jeu je
précise mme été vus m'absenter un quart
d'heure ma femme et mes enfants étaient
en tribune
ils sont venus me voir je suis pas
rentré depuis trois semaines ils m'ont
demandé s'ils sont ils sont partis pour
voir non non non non non j'ai le droit
de rappeler leurs noms
j'ai le droit d'exprimer son sentiment
sur un porteur poussé à bout par cette
série d'amendements
le rapporteur fini par craquer je vais
vous citer une citation qui m'est
revenue tout à l'heure je l'avais pas
prévu certains certains parmi vous au
déclaré la république c'est moi
et bien moi je vous dit la république
c'est nous et vous êtes en arrière
[Musique]
l'opposition crie au scandale
le rapporteur aura beau s'excuser le mal
est fait à cet instant de la partie
l'issue est inéluctable il reste trop
d'amendements pour tenir le calendrier
un troisième joueur détient la solution
le premier ministre il n'a qu'une carte
en main l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
constitution
c'est un moyen de faire adopter un texte
sans vote
il lui suffirait de poser la carte pour
remporter la partie
la séance
des reprises cette carte est impopulaire
la majorité doit donc préparé l'opinion
à ce qui va se passer
elle va alors dénoncé la coupable à ses
yeux l'obstruction
mais arrêtez de nous faire perdre du
temps arrêter de poser des à mende
demain le 9 à porter il a dit d'un
centième sont les mêmes choses assumer
le fait que vous voulez simplement faire
capoter ce projet il n'y a pas de
problème là-dessus mais le est dit est
dit aux français que vous assumez votre
obstruction arrêtez s'il vous plaît de
faire monter la sauce de faire monter la
sauce dans l'hémicycle nous sommes sur
un débat qui se déploie normalement et
vous avez là 49,3 dans toutes vos têtes
mais prenez l'air prenez l'air et
continue le débat tranquillement les
débats vont continuer normalement
pendant deux jours nous sommes un samedi
en fin de journée le secrétaire d'état
fait un signe au président de séance
monsieur le ministre je vous entends
préconçues
mais ce maïs demandent une suspension de
séance de 10 minutes allaient de droit
les députés ont du mal à y croire
le conseil des ministres at il déjà
donné son feu vert aux 49 3 il y a bien
eu une réunion du gouvernement le matin
même mais c'était pour évoquer la crise
du coronavirus la séance et reprises la
parole d'un monsieur le premier ministre
edouard philippe monte à la tribune
il abat alors l'unique carte qu'il a
entre les mains
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 et après en
avoir obtenu l'autorisation du conseil
des ministres du 29 février
[Applaudissements]
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite
je vous remercie monsieur edouard
philippe avec ses airs de dandy qui
touche à rien pour finir c'est quand
même eu la grosse brute dans cette
histoire et il se comporte d'une manière
très choquant à ce conseil des ministres
convoqué comme ça samedi
vous avez un en vedette américaine le
coronavirus et puis ensuite le clou du
spectacle le 49-3 l'assemblée nationale
ne pourra pas disputer la gauche est
prise de court
après un long conciliabule insoumis
communistes et socialistes finissent par
s'accorder sur une motion de censure
la droite a déjà déposé la sienne
il y en aura donc deux 48 heures ont
passé
nous arrivons à les pilotes de cette
bataille des retraites
à l'ordre du jour les motions de censure
et une manifestation devant l'assemblée
profitez de deux heures d'avis ruffat
ciel 43 vaut le faire thomas n'a le
droit la colère n'est toujours pas
retombée
quelques députés communistes tentent de
remonter le moral des troupes
l'histoire est pas fini c'est pas parce
qu'il a sorti le 49-3 que la
manifestation se déroule sous les
fenêtres de catherine fabre et monique
limon les deux députés en marche voulait
améliorer certains points de la réforme
mission accomplie à leurs yeux donc ça
c'est le texte qui sort de l'assemblée
nationale pour aller au sénat tous les
éléments qui sont aux couleurs sont des
éléments que les parlementaires avec
leurs travaux vers vous contribuez à
faire maudit alors il n'a pas pu
débattre mais au moins on a pu les faire
les mettre dans le texte il ya eu les
amendements qui concerne les droits
familiaux pour les parents isolés donc
une majoration de points ça n'existait
pas dans le texte initial
pareil pour les les parents d'enfants
porteurs de handicap où il ya des
préjudices de carrière quand même
important c'est le seul motif de
satisfaction pour les députés en marche
dont le texte soumis aux 49 3 le
gouvernement a retenu la plupart des
amendements de la majorité
pour le reste les deux députés garde un
goût amer de ce débat parlementaire
on est organisés d'une telle façon que
17 personnes mot vingtaine peuvent
empêcher 577 à travailler correctement
c'est grave ou moins 3 et comment on
peut dire on n'a pas réussi le 49-3
venez tous dans la revue on vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir et vous
pensez en avoir pendant longtemps sourds
aux fenêtres de députés des manifestants
qui crient on est là mais il y en a
toujours eu
c'est un peu le général qui vient saluer
ses troupes après la bataille
sauf que pour jean luc mélenchon la
bataille n'est pas finie
c'est le message qu'il veut faire passer
aujourd'hui aussi bien à ses supporters
réunis devant l'assemblée que dans son
discours de motion de censure prononcée
dans la foulée s'apprêtent à voter les
vieux permet un texte qu'ils n'ont pas
lu pas discuter et quand ils ne
connaissent aucune des conséquences
vous allez accepter de laisser passer
sans débat un texte que vous n'avez
jamais eu alors la bataille quitte
revanche maintenant est une bataille de
longue durée et non pas fini avec nous
en toute hypothèse est quoi qu'il arrive
au toute hypothèse est quoi qu'il arrive
en 2022
nous avons tout ça dès 2022 nous
annulerons tous comme j'avais fait la
promesse de jours meilleurs pour oublier
le présent car dans l'immédiat les
motions de censure sont rejetés
la majorité requise des temps pas
atteinte la motion de censure n'est pas
adoptée en conséquence est considéré
comme adopté le projet de loi instituant
un système universel de retraite la
réforme des retraites qui est ainsi
l'assemblée
en attendant la revanche et la deuxième
lecture du projet de loi
voilà donc pour cette guerre des nerfs à
l'assemblée la seconde lecture elle n'a
pas encore eu lieu et pour cause 13
jours à peine après le vote
la france a été confiné la suite ce sera
donc sans doute pour la prochaine
session parlementaire et lcp sera là
pour vous le raconter
[Musique]